hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to catch your chance now
this is a game about dating it's a
little bit of a dating simulator where
you're gonna be going out on a lovely
date and trying to score as high as you
possibly can it if there's one thing bar
bar knows about scoring just wait and
see with with you cuz she will do with
other parts of my body
excuse my drawer scratch that inch back
in my huniepop days just being a little
too eager if you know what I mean oh
yeah you got an itch baby you got an
itch okay
I got one star swimmer whoosh oh I don't
know where I'm going with this one where
where are you are you taking me okay I
guess I don't need how about I just go
straight for it
oh yeah excuse you I don't wanna scratch
the wrong itch here I'm a teacher I have
a question
scratching the itch I don't know what
you want from me if you if you if you
don't tell me what do
problems like I get it okay I get it
Goemon me of my stretchy arms I got it
hey move your legs there for a little
bit mari who's got to make some
undercover moves oh yeah oh alright that
wasn't the right way to go but you bear
with me one more time not used to these
control schemes to scratch an itch well
[Music]
origin of my arm don't worry baby whoo
baby wahoo I got this I want to impress
my own mother mom if you're watching at
this
don't be very impressed is all Gus
impress Oh impress her mom oh not my mom
okay that's fine excuse me sorry
hey let's try this again sorry what dude
why my mother
what big hair you got
well whoa hey whoa hey whoa aah
Zann egg projectile were you ain't gonna
get me mr. bird but not this time around
oh thank you for the sweet acceptance in
your hair mama
I just got it away let me try that again
I gotta get this I can't rest until I
grew even breasts from mother I got this
I am the best
look at me go on damn great look B go I
am the best on that gets a little piece
action from your daughter don't ask
about how will do that gonna touch her
on the arm right now dude very
impressive I know that right
wahoo indeed oh we need when it comes in
love markiplier best believe me I don't
know why you don't believe me
tongue-tied is we gonna get it on always
we is we gonna get a ball let's go up
here right now to detangle my tongue
your other done here we go now
hahahahaha
Georgie oh you thought you thought
that's how it's gonna go well tricks on
you it's a penis
I am the master of love call me mark a
lover man sir don't call me that
actually that's a terrible name either
way that was catch your chance so I'll
catch you on the flippety-flip in the
next video but before that would have
been a good transition it actually in
the video but here I go dragging it on
just a little bit longer so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know where you figure this down the
comments below give me your sweet sassy
dating tips down there as well and
almost forgot to blow I almost forgot to
be to blow that but either way thank you
all so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]